hat zwei mädchen die zu sitzen wir
wissen immer gehen auf dem hatten wurden
im krieg starb
wir dürfen uns nicht so viel bewegt
hallo leute ich ist wieder einmal waren
und heute bin ich nicht alleine da ich
habe die wunderschöne unglaubliche inka
dabei wir haben nämlich für den betsaal
servicekanal ein video gedreht in dem
wir über spielzeug für wachsende
sprechen und da packen wir auch unsere
privaten geheimnisse aus ich kann euch
nur sagen uns was ihr geschichten sind
dabei fast aussieht also und will man es
natürlich auch dabei wenn sowie macht
auf jeden fall einen applaus wenn ihr
keinen applaus bekommen weiß ich nicht
ob du hast du kriegen kannst ok applaus
jetzt und dafür auf dem bett als
servicekanal über spielzeug für
erwachsene besprochen haben dachte ich
lass uns doch einen adventskalender
auspacken der spielzeug für erwachsene
hart so weit ich bin so aufgeregt und
gleichzeitig bin ich auch ein bisschen
nervös der gedanke adventskalender auch
zu machen bevor weihnachten du bist der
gast ich bin zwar bei dir aber du darfst
türchen nummer eins auf machen ja aber
ich finde die einst nicht das fing schon
gut da das fenster auch vor dem ersten
dezember gott denkt okay das ist prima
wird es gleich mal aus bekommt das baby
wird kardinal eingeführt am flexiblen
rückhol bändchen das ist sich jederzeit
wieder herausziehen durch die
fernbedienung kann dem partner die
kontrolle überlassen werden egal ob
daheim oder unterwegs das ist dieses
neue spielzeug was erzählt hinter der
werbende und dann irgendwie in dem
restaurant sitzt und dann so ich habe
mich gerade auf dieses tür das gefühlt
dieses die sicherheitsbestimmungen sie
ziehen das bändchen nimmst mir handvoll
groß aber die fernbedienung sieht aus
wie so eine maus die leute dass sie das
wird noch mal witzig mal drauf ich habe
mal eine wilde party gelehrt dass es die
an die nase halten
okay aber das fühlst du ich verstehe das
nicht
wenn man sein bootleg okay das ist der
größte spaß daran
das ist kein spiel sache sagt mir so
bewertungskategorien ausdenken fand
faktor du kannst auf den boden legen und
es sieht aus wie eine springende maus
wird sein befand faktor acht von zehn ja
design als auch schon ziemlich serie
geholt wo der golf ist ein see von sehen
ja auch gerade gedacht die hälfte der
zuschauer denkt sich gerade so jetzt
cool die packen erwachsenenspielzeug aus
und die andere hälfte denkst du hast du
gut wir hatten jetzt ein spielzeug
spielzeug mix klappt es sieht aus wie
bleibt gleich mittel auf wasserbasis
sehr glücklich macht haus nicht so ölig
kriegt man hilfe schließlich kann man
aber auch eine kondome deswegen benutzen
wir uns auf ölbasis oder so dann reißen
können wenn du das machst muss man öfter
pro tipp von inka wir können wir drei
machen und dann drei pause drei und 3000
türchen nummer drei
das sieht komisch aus ich habe angst
davor sie aus wie eine lupe ratet mal
was ist hast du gelebt hat
ich weiß es okay also der fraktionen
banane rein und das soll dann eine
rosine stimulieren so weit den kopf
meine hand ring
das könnte auch aussehen wie sind
flaschenöffner oder mir nur einen
flaschenöffner hast kannst du diesen
flaschenöffner für 25 euro aus kopiert
die sein würde ich sagen wieder zehn von
zehn weil du kannst es so legen lassen
auf was hier auch in ein bisschen also
dass der coolste flaschenöffner den ich
hier hat nummer sieben manager wie
collection mit helic chain whitney ist
eine kette okay ich es mir vorgestellt
aber kommt hat schon wehgetan
also nicht viel aber jetzt tue was ich
dir sage was ist unsers award will man
also wer denkt dass das jetzt so eine
peitsche ist aber ja ich würde das
niemals denken da ich habe keine 80 eur
8 höhe gespannt wie das ist wenn du zu
spät bist du bist du wieder pünktlich
sagt lang gar das ist für männer die
sich zu schnell freuen
ja das habe ich einfach ist wie ein
stier dieser adventskalender dass ich
mich auf die paare denn was haben wir
bei unserem gespräch lernt wie spoiler
es jetzt nicht geht auf den besser als
neues kanal zu sehen worüber wir
gesprochen
[Musik]
das ist ein großes rad also damit kann
man ganz große fehler auslöschen zum
beispiel dass freunde ja die vergisst
man einmal ganz schnell
und das hat aber auch seine neue
funktion damit ist so richtig gute
radiert ganz einfach hier und dann
kannst du alles wegradieren ich möchte
die gis daraus nicht sehen so das
vibriert müssen wir natürlich wieder den
ultimativen bewegte sich test machen ja
es bewegt sich auf den boden
also ich finde das ein bisschen ekelhaft
wie dasjenige das würstchen
das design für mein land ich richtig
schlecht aus chicago ein ganz kleines
paket
wir sind jetzt aber mal ganz
professionell und erwachsen denn sie
sind erwachsene menschen sind ist das so
eine kette da kannst du eine kleine dran
machen oder
hier steht auch schon geträumt dieses
fashion accessoire vectron das fantasie
bondage vorschrift wiegen herrscht wie
in den meisten nicht zum strangulieren
verwenden bitte bringt euch nicht damit
um danke das kostet auch fünf funktion
25 euro um 00 14 ganze dünnes paket the
manhunters muss verstärkt private sektor
konkret spektor g das ist wenn du nicht
so gut in die hintertür rein kommt also
so wenn du nicht vornherein wenn du
deine schlüssel vergessen hast und dann
beten also über die küche dann ins haus
möchte muss halt irgendwie das fenster
auf kriegen
das kriegst du mal cleaning spray damit
du deine teils auch klinik st
[Musik]
das sieht auch sehen dass das zu hinten
aufs handy auch machst damit zugreifen
kann
da guckt das machst du so hinten an
deinem handy traf und dann hängst du das
wird man kann sogar fotos mache ich aber
gut an
also wirklich das ist und handy teil
scheiße auf pocket hier masturbation
teufel man einfach einen finger durch
die schlaffe führen
wir sind popblog gegen vergeben wir mal
wieder punkte aber es passiert halt
nicht so stark punkte also ich mag
topflappen deswegen bitte ich jetzt
damit auch noch du hast wieder ein böses
mädchen entsprechend steht wirklich
spank nie drauf treibt sie nicht sanft
mit dem arzt zwar über die haut wagens
bevor lange intensivere klasse verteilt
tipp der po und schenkel eignet sich
besonders gut für das spiel ausmacht und
feuer unterwerfung sieht aus wie ein
schuh anziehen also ich finde wir können
uns ein bisschen mit unseren geben
doch wie sieht ein richtig curanum
hintergrund eines videos kerzen hat
hilft ist als eine normale karte in
nachbarländer wie gut sind alle
ladenketten begründet seine kerze die zu
müssen andere die mit ganz schnell zu
ändern hat es als massagen verwenden es
schon vorgeworfen
ich muss es so machen
es kostet 8 euro also für das bisschen
[Musik]
wir haben auch schon den flaschenöffner
wir hatten schon den flaschen für
längeres vergnügen warum weil er die
alles ab drückt und gespürt und trank im
jahr hat so ein spielzeug für dich volk
gut männer so du darfst nicht also ich
finde dieser kalender lohnt sich schon
erst wirklich ach steuer deswegen kann
sich den kaum jemand leisten wenn man
ihn nicht von der steuer absetzen kann
und muss man jetzt würdest du ihn
gekauft
also ich meine topflappen für 25 euro
ist ein bisschen hart aber ich muss
sagen was mich überzeugt war dieses
hintertürchen weil es so oft dass ich
mein schlüssel vergessen hier aber ich
finde ich glaube ich würde nie war das
geld in eine sache die ich halt wirklich
möglich haben will aber ich glaube das
finde ich bei allen adventskalendern
auch so ein beauty adventskalender was
will ich mit so nem zeigt was dann doch
nicht wirklich browser 100 proben ja ja
und dann kam ich mir lieber eine große
gesagt also das war's mit dem videos war
es super cool mit dir den gemütlichen
vormittag hin zu verbringen und spritzig
auszupacken
ich hoffe euch hat das video nicht zu
sehr verstört weil ihr uns noch richtig
bock auf uns beide hat dann geht auf den
websites servicekanal also auf dieses
video denn da reden wir über spielzeug
für erwachsene
ich bin die nächste k der kassa bitten
wenn ich erstmal silikon in meine brüste
kriege dann ist aber hier wo afrika kann
und hier ist natürlich auch noch inkas
kanal falls sie wissen wollte wer diese
schöne rothaarige frau ist